bueno pues es el debate entre manuel
marco y los 11 jóvenes
líderes africanos ha sido quizás lo
mejor de esta jornada ha sido un debate
en el que se ha hablado con bastante
franqueza con mucha determinación y
energía de hecho estos jóvenes varias
veces se ganaron los aplausos y los
vítores de las miles de personas que
están presentes allí en esta plenaria
que finalmente ya está llegando a
término en todo caso de que hablaron a
bueno el presidente le preguntaron por
una parte le dijeron por favor hay que
cambiar ciertas cosas dentro del
vocabulario para cambiar también la
visión que tiene áfrica del continente
africano siempre esa visión digamos de
miseria de pobreza de desempleo de
enfermedad y una de esas palabras que
hieren todavía que son muy relativas a
pues es desarrolló una palabra que está
incluida dentro de la agencia francesa
de desarrollo de durante 80 años ha
obrado en ese país precisamente para
ayudar al desarrollo de ese continente
el presidente dijo que efectivamente ese
era un cambio que debía hacerse uno de
los momentos tal vez más difíciles es
cuando estos jóvenes le hicieron
preguntas incómodas al presidente
francés por una parte sobre el apoyo que
francia
he estado dando a varios regímenes
autoritarios como por ejemplo en chad o
en mali pero también sobre la presencia
militar en francia en especial allí en
la región de sahel y las bases militares
francesas el presidente bueno supo
manejar todas estas respuestas explicó
cómo había sucedido dijo que la idea de
este fondo para el desarrollo de
iniciativas democráticas que tendrá 30
millones de euros para comenzar pues
será manejado precisamente por africanos
que estén trabajando en iniciativas que
ayuden a promover la democracia en este
tipo de países y en cuanto a las bases
militares pues el presidente ha sintió
que efectivamente lo que él quiere es
eso que haya un retiro de las tropas
francesas pero pero para esto se
necesita por una parte que haya unos
estados fuertes y que en última es esto
quede también en manos de organizaciones
internacionales como la onu así que aquí
se ha dado un intercambio de ideas
bastantes fuertes y bueno pues de todas
maneras se espera que este sea un
momento histórico eso decían a los
jóvenes a partir de ahora esta sea una
de las muchas citas que esperan entre
francia y el continente africano